dans la cour d'honneur de la préfecture
trompettes et tambours font retentir la
marseillaise ce mardi ont célébré la
mémoire des policiers morts pour la
france
en maître de cérémonie erard corbin de
mangoux le nouveau préfet des yvelines
accompagné du président du conseil
général lecture du message du ministre
de l'intérieur et dépôt de gerbes ont
ponctué cet hommage hommage aux morts
mais également aux vivants pour clore
cette cérémonie
des policiers se sont vus récompensés
pour des actes de bravoure
parmi eux christophe denis qui en mai
2012 à participer à une intervention à
domicile dans le cadre d'une
hospitalisation psychiatrique
on frappe à la porte ils n'ouvrent pas
et nous dise si vous rentrez je me tue
je vais me tuer ont fini par essayer de
pousser un peu la porte et là ils
l'ouvrent violemment il se trouvait
juste derrière et ils plantent mon
collègue et lui porte un coup de couteau
au niveau de l'épaule
donc mon pot de colle mon collègue se
met derrière moi et du coup je sors mon
arme
et je maintiens distance et j'ai le
regret plus pendant dix minutes un quart
d'heure avec l'appui de mon collègue ads
qui passe un message radio pour demander
des renforts en 12 ans de carrière un
cas qui reste pour lui exceptionnel son
collègue protégé par son gilet
pare-balles n'a heureusement pas été
grièvement blessé